[Musique]
sous les fenêtres de françois 1er louis
xii et bien d'autres rois de france
juste en face de chez maria c'est
l'affluence au rond point bas ils ont
fait pour moi ça il centrait pour moi
les responsables politiques
d'aujourd'hui inaugurant en grande pompe
la tour d'or blanc 14 mètres de haut un
ingrédient de plus dans le panorama des
clients du royal en terrasse j'espère
que ce sera une chose de plus qu'il veut
un quorum du monde tant mieux pour les
commerçants ya d'extraordinaire pour moi
c'est une passerelle pour ce quartier
d'amboise qui a été un peu délaissé la
nuit s'est illuminé c'est sympa au bout
de quelques temps les français mais
attention on passe à côté tous les jours
lui fera plus attention non non c'est
beau un petit peu surprenante au début
mais on va très vite l'intégrer on
suppose que c'est le rose et le blanc
vin blanc pour les couleurs donc voilà
passé ce que je pense mais bon
que l'on arrive de blois tours ou
amboise la tour sera désormais la trace
patrimoniale 21e siècle
c'est clair la nuit donc c'est vraiment
comme un phare au bord de la loire qui
rappelle les anciens fars on pourrait
retrouver et puis c'est ces ponts qui
nous disent mâconnais dans le quartier
du bout des ponts un phare un toit de
pagodes la viticulture la batellerie ou
tout simplement une lanterne qui est là
pour marquer la bordure de la loire la
tour parle d'abord des vignerons des
vignes du vin le chemin le coup le
touraine amboise et bientôt l'amb oise
ce qui est important c'est ce que les
vignerons est en butte avec un ami
et donc là dessus il ya plus qu'un
problème les qualités sont magnifiques
au niveau de surtout des exploitations
et donc voilà donc sa population
angoissée sera je pense pour bientôt
vous pour lui rendre hommage le lycée
viticole a fait couler le vin cuvée de
la tour l'étiquette et les verts sont
déjà collector et comme le dit le slogan
de la confrérie nauroy l'on aimé alors
[Musique]